[Music]
thank you
oh my God
let's vote everybody let's vote
[Music]
oh it's that um
monster that trans thing that looks like
Keith Lee
remember that I was at the MTV Awards
looks like Keith Lee talks like sunny
kiss
es
if you're not voting you don't get laid
because that's a rule yeah no voting no
[ __ ] so no I don't want to [ __ ] any
of you people so that's fine wow racist
so I didn't mean that like that and then
people in the video
so this one here you wouldn't smash
don't fall
but that's because he has a felony
yeah
like legally he can't do it mad at him
cause he can't have a gun on him too are
you mad at him but he can't give birth
to a child
it's not his fault
I mean it's his fault but it's only a
first strike it's one strike
I have 7-Eleven voting ever been a deal
breaker if you're trying to get your
dick sucked no and by the way you know
you lie
yeah I don't even know this men lie
sometimes to have sex
no
I don't really follow politics you're
like
deal breaker this is just gonna make
voting look gay as [ __ ] to black people
God's name like that gay [ __ ] Yuki
barked at me give me one second I'm
sorry [ __ ] I'll be here
well there you go he's gone and he's
gone
upper comes first folks
Papa always comes first
I mean the kitties come first I'm just
gonna just gonna Twitter
from Astoria
and I was just wondering what is your
ideal uh you know I was there I was just
wondering
well you know I mean come on what are
you gonna make food for you in a store
you got the best Greek food ever am I
right come on hey next caller
I hate you guys
came back came back to this Chris Como
hour again
um
okay I'm done with this is that Trina
oh no that's Trina Miami Queen Trina
[Music]
you want to continue don't you I want to
back that ass up anymore with you
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
thanks Trina
[Music]
her pussy's like Universal Health Care
anyone can get it
pretty good
I hate where we live
[Laughter]
[Music]
if you want to come come before the
deadline
[Laughter]
can we just have her first I just want
her can I can we reverse again come on
guys she wants us to congressionally
redistrict her vagina yes correct
by the way in an advantageous way for
republicans
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
gerrymander this coochie is [ __ ]
great she's one of yours isn't she she's
not she's Miami but she's not Cuban no
but I didn't mean Cuban I meant one of
yours yeah she's one of your Florida
she's she's the one that used to be on
all the Trick Daddy [ __ ]
hear me out she's Trina she backed that
ass up her her verse sounds like oh no
whoop whoop that ass is too fat that's
her her verse sounds like if to queel
from frisky dingo did a [ __ ] track
about voting and had a female on it okay
just hear me just hear me out just hear
me out just one more time okay
legs in the air I don't care anyone
could get a universe
[Laughter]
gerrymander this Coochie Man
[Laughter]
serious anymore now why why would you
well who do you think this is who cares
[ __ ] ludicrous comes out of nowhere
yeah it's the recount this come in your
mouth
okay